the trick that I used was really very
simple I asked how how would you like to
underwrite um or to give credit cards to
10,000 Google
Engineers as you can imagine everybody
wants to do that and once you agree on
that then the question the next question
is okay so are eBay Engineers the same
as Google Engineers McKenzie Consultants
B gold and you start expanding from
there but that was I think the initial
hook to get the interest welcome to
20-minute leaders just sit back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get
[Music]
started this episode is parted by Jay
Ventures a community-driven VC Fund in
silon Valley in partnership with lch and
sponsored by Homewood Ventures hippo
Insurance opwest hell at Stanford leap
and Birthright Excel welcome to another
episode of twin minute leaders and I
think we can all agree that it's time to
properly change the way we assign credit
and lend money
meet elor rosenrot CEO of Jasper
formerly credit stxs elor is the CEO and
co-founder of the credit card company
Jasper formerly known as credit stxs
previously ELO was co-founder and CEO of
mobile advertising platform ping Jem and
VP of New Growth platforms at LG
Electronics elor holds an MBA from the
tuck School of Business at Dartmouth and
a bachelor's degree in law from the
academic College of Law in Tel Aviv El
no Rosen rot welcome to 20-minute
leaders the CEO of Jasper how are you
you I'm doing very well today how are
you doing thank you I'm doing I'm doing
great I'm I'm catching you in Israel H
generally you're stationed out of out of
New York with 52 employees raised $30
million and and we're going to have to
talk about this idea that you're that
you're going to aim to recruit 300
employees by by 20 by the end of 2022 I
have no idea how to even fathom that as
a young entrepreneur H and and we're
going to talk about the fintech world
but even before we get there
I have to ask about star down with a
bear it the story has to be
told uh yes I had a stare down with a
bear essentially when I when I first
moved to the states I I I saw the
company I founded here in Israel and
moved to the states to get to get an NBA
and I went I went up to uh to Dartmouth
to talk which is sort of in the middle
of nowhere in New Hampshire a beautiful
area and I was sitting outside one day
working and suddenly I hear shrieks
excitement uh you know coming from my
left side and I look over and I see
three of my Japanese neighbors kind of
pointing in my direction and W with
massive enthusiasm and I thought to
myself maybe I should Mo to Japan but
then I realized that they weren't
actually looking at me they were looking
at a bear that was about 30 ft away from
me rumaging through the trash area of
the compound so I looked at the bear the
bear looked at me it continued rumaging
through a trash I continued working that
was it the fun part though is we sent a
letter to the housing office of the
University to ask what to do with the
bear and they said just leave the bear
Alone um in the entire history of the
school only one student was ever killed
in 1911 or something like that so
obviously I immediately notified my
parents that I would a bear in the
backyard and it's only killed one
student so
far amazing unbelievable now H that
isn't the the inspiration for Jasper
that that is for another experience but
but but this is an amazing story tell me
about your your moving to to the United
States um credit score ftech and and how
you know 2021 is positioned to be an
interesting time for the this whole idea
of credit scores and credit
lines sure um so the story actually
starts exactly at that time um I I moved
to the US I I found an insult a company
here in Israel uh moved to the US to get
an NBA and I I couldn't get a credit
card and it just drove me nuts I didn't
understand understand why just because I
was on a 12-hour flight I suddenly
turned from someone that Banks actually
enjoyed working with I hope to someone
that just didn't exist as far as the
system was concerned and it took me
quite a long time to go through the
motions and build my own uh build my
credit score and get access to decent
credit um but the story actually turns
into Jasper card um somewh around 2015
when I reached out U to a gentleman by
the name of SAR will SAR is one of the
fathers U of the Israeli fch industry he
was the founder and CEO of company
called fraud Sciences which to this day
is at the core of uh of risk decisioning
for uh for papal uh
worldwide and I approached him actually
with a very simple question the question
was look this credit score uh credit
bureau structure works fairly well for
80% of the people 80% of the time but
what about the others you know what
about the other people what about the
other times and we came up with a simple
logically but very tricky actually
solution to this which is why don't we
underwrite based on people's future now
the easiest way to to understand that is
think about someone who's just
graduating from college you know 22 year
old uh not much of a credit history but
they've got a job offer at Goldman for
instance that's that's probably a decent
future ahead of them think of someone
that's just relocated from outside of
the US to be a Google engineer again no
credit history whatsoever but a great
financial future ahead of them so that
was the original premise with which we
with which we started we fired up a
1,000 card pilot uh with a with a small
uh with a small Bank uh run the pilot
for a year to test the thesis see see
whether it actually holds in real life
the the results by the way were were
astounding we managed to come in at
about 4X uh the uh the industry
benchmarks if you will um both on uh
both on charge offs and and on spend per
card and a whole array of other metrics
and and on the back of that we went and
signed an agreement uh with a new
issuing Bank a much bigger issuing Bank
um that and went through an imp
implementation process uh and launched
um and that bank gave us first of all an
unlimited issuance capacity um and
second uh receivable facility a credit
facility basically of $100 million that
we started using to actually lend people
money through credit cards um so that's
uh that's s of the inial story and just
to share some general metrics since
we've laun launched as card about a year
ago um it's been going fairly well we've
been growing 20% month over month uh
both in terms of customer acquisition
rates uh and and the whole set of other
metrics so so
far things seem to be going in the right
direction and and we're actually
planning a whole Suite of new exciting
project s that are going to come uh come
live uh before the end of this year wow
incredible and so first impressions on
on this whole this idea you're going to
banks that are very used to the credit
score system you know it's a very risk
averse system H in place you're sitting
down with the with with people do they
buy into it are they skeptical do they
laugh what what
happens so I think the most important
thing to understand about Banks is um
they are extremely focused on compliance
and making sure that they don't do
anything that's going to land them in
into hot water with a regulator so the
general incentive is to not rock the
boat too much so the vast majority of
banks you you you'll go and talk to just
have no desire to do anything that is
different from what they've done in the
past 10 20 30 years that there is a
small subset of banks that are actually
willing to do uh that are actually
willing to do uh newer things willing to
do different things but even then the
first thing they're always concerned
about is or the first question to go
through their mind is are you going to
get us in trouble with the regulator
because if you do this entire thing is
just not worth it um so there's a very
big component of building trust with the
with the Bank building a relationship
building trust making sure that they um
get a sense get a level of comfort that
you're actually a partner that they can
go that they can work with that will not
that will not cause them any any kind of
grief so I think that's really that's
really the key part to begin with and
coming out at the time we were starting
out of Israel so coming out with a team
of let's call it the the classic startup
team of you know a tech guy and a risk
guy and and a business guy the you know
the the the the the holy Trio if you
will that everybody talks about with the
Hustler and the the designer and all
that um and going to a
bank actually scares Banks some
sometimes because they see a startup and
startups are sort of known for you know
moving fast and break thing breaking
things doing all sorts of things that do
not work very well in a in a compliance
heavy environment so in order to help
create that trust we actually um had a
fourth co-founder with us who was a
former division director at the FDIC and
uh in a board member for banks
and once we went into a room with that
entire with that
team and became apparent to our banking
uh Partners potential partners that we
were very serious about compliance about
building a company that would actually
um have in its core DNA um all all the
required components to work
appropriately to work the right way only
then we were able to really start
talking seriously about the business and
then it's a question of how much they
believe in uh in your business case um I
can tell you that the trick that I Ed
was really very simple I asked how how
would you like to underwrite um or to
give credit cards to 10,000 Google
Engineers as you can imagine everybody
wants to do that and once you agree on
that then the question the next question
is okay so are eBay Engineers the same
as Google Engineers McKenzie Consultants
B gold and you start expanding from
there but that was I think the initial
hook to get the
interest so as the as the CEO and
co-founder how how do you go through
thinking about the validation for the
startup right so you're starting out
obviously today after raising you know
$30 million and you're already working
in in Banks I'm I'm listening to this
idea and to this new concept of of
measuring somebody's ability to pay back
through what they do and not through
their history which is you know it's
it's just so different from how the
United States currently thinks through
its system how do you think through you
know your Milestones of validation was
there was it you know a single turning
point where you say okay now I proved
that we can actually grow this at scale
or is this is it more you know very
small building
blocks so I I don't think there's any
one point in which you sort of go aha
this this is it I figured this out and
now from now on it's just a small matter
of execution as a friend of mine likes
to say um it's there's constant proof
points that you that you run through so
and the credit card space or anything
that's really uh that's really related
to uh to
banking one of the biggest challenges is
that you can't do you know the classic
MVP strategy of let's just roll
something out no matter how it works
whether it's broken or not and see
whether the customers respond to it
right everything you advertise that gets
put in front of a customer needs to go
through compliance and obviously there
needs to be truth in lending and truth
in advertising so you can't
just be creative or take any Liberties
around presenting things things that you
don't have which almost means that you
need to build the the entire thing you
need to actually be able to start
issuing credit cards in order to start
getting real feedback because everything
anything else you do before that is more
focus groups than real customer feedback
that you can work with that you can
actually touch so there's a lot of
validation points in the process uh
there's a lot of points where you learn
that what you thought isn't exactly
reality um and that's uh that what
customers want is not necessarily what
you thought they want but nonetheless it
still makes sense so I think there's
this combination of on the one hand
having a conviction that there is a path
that you can carve through this that
will land you on a on a solution on a
product that customers will actually
love and respond to in Mass um while
understanding that you're going to have
to go blind at least initially before
you start launch before you launch an
and actually start getting feedback and
even then there's a limit to how fast
you can iterate because again this is
the banking industry so everything needs
to be laid out perfectly right and when
you launch things need to be well fully
worked out you can't just launch a
partial product so it's a very
interesting industry it's a very
challenging industry uh to operate in
which is honestly part of the reasons I
love it in incredible and it sounds like
you're you're at a point now where where
you're about to grow massively and
you're already you're already on on that
track and so what what what are the
biggest challenges that you're
positioning yourself with you know as
you're thinking okay now how do you how
do you do this of the economies of
scale
so I think there's there's several
elements to this one is we we we had to
initially I remember the first time we
got our first customer and then the
first 100 customers and the first time
we got 100 customers a month and then
there there's all these small mils that
help you build confidence in your
ability to really execute on the growth
that you the growth potential that you
see um and we got at some point um
several months ago to to to a place that
we felt that confidence that we had a
sense of of yes we can do this we can we
can pull this off uh we can actually
grow at a at a very at a very radical
rate um and then it really becomes a
question it really becomes a matter of
being able to go and attract the right
talents to uh to to grow on it and
attract the right Capital to be able to
execute on that and and spend the CAC
and everything else that goes that goes
into that but I think for
us once we reach that level of um
confidence I'm not going to say Comfort
because I don't think we'll ever be
comfortable really um we we we're
Paranoid by definition um once we
receive we reach that level of um of of
confidence if you will that we that we
can actually execute this then we we
actually step back and ask and ask
ourselves is this all all we can be is
this all we wanted all we want to be and
one of as you start looking around you
realize that the banking industry uh
with all the great things it's it's done
for customers um is not fully caught up
with the times and if you think about
the way for instance that power has
shifted throughout the years you know 20
years ago institutions had power now you
and I have the power to take on hedge
funds by using Rob Ood even though most
of the time we will lose you and I have
the power to take on cab monopolies by
using Uber and then there's many more
examples the banking industry isn't
there yet by the way the best place you
can see it is you just look at the
spreads Banks and these are numbers from
about two or three weeks ago they will
give you 0.05% for your deposits and
they will um then turn around and give
the exact same money as a loan sometimes
to you for 10.4 49%
and they keep the entire margin now if
you think about where the world is
going there shouldn't be that Gap
because I can tell you that this is not
all for risk there's a lot of it that
goes to various other expenses
so the way that we look at this the way
the world should be is if you're lending
money I don't know for instance uh at 6%
then you should keep somewhere around I
don't know 2% U to cover your costs and
your risks and actually give give 4% of
your customers CU it's their money it's
their resources that's the way the world
should
work and to a great degree that's the
direction that we're going towards now
um for various compliance reasons I
can't talk about what products we're
rolling out and what exactly we're doing
until we actually do it um but we think
there's a lot of work to be done there's
a lot of there's a lot of ground to be
covered by bundling credit cards because
credit cards are just one small
component of your financial life with a
deposit account with um lines of credit
or or loan products um and
building first of all something that's
actually Fair let's start there just
make it fair where everybody wins and
not just one party and
two if you think about your financial
life and I obviously spend a lot of time
thinking about people's Financial lives
including mine it's it's a bit of a mess
because there's there's a lot different
Financial products that you are expected
to learn you're expected to
master and you're trying to run your
financial life sort of in 30 seconds
after dinner while you're making other
plans while on the other side of the
playing field there's a whole p&l team
in the bank that actually knows what
they're doing right so it's it's not
it's not really fair to require you to
have to learn all these products I think
the best way I can think about it is if
you think about your car for a second
when you get into your car in the
morning I mean it's made of tens of
thousands of
pieces but you don't care where the ties
are from or where the engine's from you
just press a button and you trust your
car to take you where where you need to
go and that's the way finances should
work so we're sort of aspiring to to
build that type of experience around
much more of your finances than just the
credit
card you know I'm I'm enjoying this
conversation so much you're giving me
ease of mind because I know how how uh
you know my lack of abilities to manage
my own finances and to understand how
this complicated structure works and and
I never understand why everybody says
that I need to understand it so well H
why does everybody need to understand it
so well it's 10,000 moving pieces and
and and so I can't wait for for Jasper
to continue and and helping people like
myself and like millions of others
around the world H live better
financially viable lives and and and
take ownership over what we do and and
so elor thank you for coming here and
sharing your time
and and energy and and sharing the story
I really really enjoyed it and I want to
take you back to your childhood with a
few short questions H starting with your
childhood what really fascinated you as
a kid what whether it's a was a passion
project or or a subject in
school so I I I think there's there's
two things that I was always fascinated
by one is breaking things apart and then
trying to put them together I wasn't
always successful um the amount of
watches and cameras and other items that
I took apart car engines and sort of put
it back together is uh was painful for
my parents um the other thing I was
actually fascinated by was I know this
might sound a bit weird but by idleness
by doing nothing just by giving myself
the time to I know to dream to think uh
and I and I sort of find that today I
gravitate back towards that once in a
while when I need to when I need to
really step back and figure something
out so I think those if if You' ask my
parents those are the two things they
remember the most about me amazing and
if we look fast forward to today some
something or somebody that inspires you
on your
journey so I I
get I guess for me it it's
all I I think I'm an extremely lucky
person because I get to
to wake up every morning and work at
something that I'm truly truly deeply
passionate about and by the way it's not
about the solution because I could we
could be wrong about the solution it's
it's the problem you know
helping helping helping people deal with
this problem solving this problem it's
it's it's an amazing puzzle and the
compliment to that is that I get to play
the you know the adult version of Lego
blocks if you will you know we we we get
all of us the company uh we we we get to
just build things that didn't existed
before and to me that's that's the true
inspiring things I mean obviously
there's people that I that I can learn
from there's people that I think have
done amazing things but I'm much more
inspired by the problem by the journey
um and by the journey than I am by
someone specific um
so that's that's usually what drives me
very very cool and what are three words
that you would use to describe
yourself H um
words well I'm definitely an
entrepreneur mhm I'm very
curious and I just love to build things
to get things
done very very cool elor TOA thank you
very very much best of luck with Jasper
I can't wait to use it myself and to and
and to continue seeing it grow and and
and continue expanding to more parts of
the of the financial ecosystem and thank
you for taking the time to share this
with
me of course thanks all for having me
and look forward to meeting again when
the time's right
[Music]